items 17 18 which can be heard together
item 17 uc
210280 use permit for a single-family
residential plan unit development
design reviews for the following
single-family residential plan unit
development finish grade on 563 acres in
an ru
rural open land zone in the red rock
overlay design district
generally located 3 700 feet north of sr
159 approximately 1.5 miles west of the
intersection
with sr 160 and
sr 159 item 18 tm 2150083 tenant map
consisting of 280 residential lots and
common lots on
563 acres
okay is there an applicant here for
items 17 and 18.
good morning good morning
good morning madam chair members of the
commission
my name is ron crater and i am a
community planner
representing gypsum resources we're
before you today
presenting to this commission a
tentative track map and planned unit
development application
meeting single family homes on
approximately 564 acres
on the land referred to as blue diamond
hill
this proposal is consistent with and
without waiver to rights
and prior approvals clark county made
representations
to the court that gypsum had a duty to
mitigate damages
and could proceed with development
planned applications
under current zoning are you rural open
lands
these two applications before you today
do just that
additionally clark county affirmed that
if the development plans were
within current zoning thresholds with no
increase
in density or intensity gypsum is not
required to take access from the east
connecting to state route 160.
following the county's assertions gypsum
immediately prepared
a master plan tentative track map
and planned unit development application
for 464 acres
the application was submitted in
february 2021
following five rounds of review with
county staff
we have before you today the final
application
and staff's recommendation for approval
we believe these applications meet or
exceed all policies goals objectives and
standards
within clark county the application is
of the highest
quality it's class defining
residential community that consists of
280 lots
on 564 acres
the gross overall density is at 0.5
units per acre
i am pleased to answer any questions
directly related
to these two applications
additionally i'm joined today by jerry
slater with westwood the civilian
involved in the project and he also is
willing to
answer any and all questions directly
related to these two applications
thank you very much thank you and that
completes your presentation
um these are public hearing items so
anybody wishing to speak on item 17 and
18 you can come up now
and i can help uh encourage pauline
heather sheila and michelle
good morning good morning
commission commissioners um can i ask a
really
quick question and you can tell me if
you can answer it or not
are you going to be able to vote on this
today
so um miss fisher it's before us so i'm
assuming that
um that will happen so if you could just
state and spell your name for the record
go ahead
okay thank you so much my statement
for the save redrock board
for the record my name is heather fisher
29 cerritos street blue diamond nevada i
am the president of save red rock
and on behalf of state rhetoric i want
to thank the clark county commission
for the opportunity to comment on this
important issue
we are an organization that has a
mission to preserve protect and enhance
the natural
cultural recreation and scenic resources
in
and around the red rock canyon national
conservation area
the topic before you is an important one
because it has relevance not only to the
mission of safe red rock but to the
entire community
as red rock canyon is treasured by all
nevadans and visitors worldwide
you are being asked today to approve its
use permit design review and tentative
map
by gypsum resources save redrock is not
now and has never been opposed to
private citizens developing their
private property according to
their development rights and within
their allowable planning codes
however what is before you is not right
for decision because the project
does not fit within clark county code
opponents have not proven legal access
to the project site
or the ability to develop any access to
standards
described in the application and not to
mention the legal pressures
of the timing of the prevailing lawsuit
the proposed
subdivision access is currently serving
as a mine hall road for gypsum resources
mining activities
in 2005 this mine hall road right of way
was relinquished by the james hardy mine
and in
2012 the bureau of land management blm
accepted the relinquishment the current
owner subsequently appealed that
relinquishment decision by blm and the
case went to the department of interior
board of land appeals ibla where they
sustained the blm decision it is unclear
if there is any legal access
granted for the mine hall road from the
blm additionally given that the
proponents have not proven legal access
to the project site
it would be a waste of taxpayer money to
continue to use staff time
and resources to process this
application i am concerned that this
application is not right for decision we
don't want to waste taxpayer money and
time
staff staff time on an application that
does not comply with clark county code
therefore i am asking the commission to
deny the application until first
the planning staff has reviewed the
applicant's package against the clark
county red rock design overlay district
code sections 30.48.280 through
30.48.400
second that legal access is proven third
that the road traversing red rock canyon
national conservation area
can meet standards outlined in the
application and fourth that the proposed
access road meets all safety and fire
protection standards
and finally that the applicant can prove
the ability to bring necessary utilities
and water etc to the property i thank
you very much for your time
and i look forward to working with you
in the future
thanks thank you mrs fisher next speaker
please
even one second there you go
good morning madam chair and the board
of clark county commissioners
my name is pauline van benton and i
reside at 17 matarango street
i've been working to protect redrock can
i get you to spell your last name for us
ben betten that's v as in victor a n
b as in boy e
i've been working to protect red rock
canyon for 20 years and there have been
many chapters
in 2001 when a massive housing
subdivision was proposed for the heart
of red rock canyon
there was a major public outcry clark
county responded by creating a task
force to address these concerns and i
was appointed as a member of that task
force
this task force created the red rock
overlay
subsequently the applicant gypson
resources took legal action
against sb 358 and the redrock design
overlay in 2010 the county entered into
a settlement agreement with chips and
resources
there were two major components to the
agreement gypsum resources would be
allowed to submit a major project
application on this
prop on his property in an exception
area to the red rock overlay
in return the applicant could not have
primary access to the major project from
scenic byway 159 which runs through red
rock canyon
i'll leave this document with you that
has all the
dates and the quotes however this
application before you today is not a
major project application and therefore
these rules do not apply
so the applicant is requesting primary
access from scenic byway 159
and since this is not a major project it
is not exempt from redrock overlay
in the settlement agreement major
projections
for the redrock overlay why is that
important there are two primary areas of
concern with the application as it
relates to the redrock overlay
clustering in section 30-48-21
clustered development shall only be
considered in conjunction with approved
major project
this is a clustering project this is a
planned unit development and it requires
clustering
and yet the redrock overlay says
clustering is not allowed unless it's a
major project
second of concern is the building
envelope in section 30-48-320
each lot shall contain a building
envelope surrounded by a natural area
the building envelope delineates the
maximum area
in which any proposed building may be
erected the building
envelope shall be located in the center
of the lot and in no
case shall it be located clear than 25
feet from the property line
this application proposes a minimum lot
size of 7041 square feet
with setbacks of 20 feet from the front
five feet from the side 10 feet from the
corner and 20 feet from the rear
none of these setbacks meet the
requirements of the red redrock overlay
natural area and building envelope
and this application is not exempt from
the redrock overlay
this application does not meet title 30
code
and it must be denied thank you
may i leave these documents with you
that cite this
code absolutely thank you thank you
okay next speaker please
if you can if i could get everybody to
state and spell their name i'd like to
help the clerk
madam chair and members of the clark
county commission my name is sheila
billingsley billingsley is spelled
b-i-l-l-i-n-g-s-l-e-y
to you to the board of county
commissioners agenda sheets specifically
public works development review
and the analysis of current planning in
the documented
in the documents generated by staff
these departments
specifically express the need to
demonstrate
paved legal access and the ability to
provide utilities to a planned unit
development
as ms fisher told us earlier gypsum
resources
lost the right-of-way to the mine hall
road
that was in place before the enabling
legislation
of the red rock canyon national
conservation area in 1990
before 1990 it was still the wild west
out there and pretty much anything goes
attitude prevailed
after november 16 1990
that all changed the enabling
legislation
of the nca is very specific
on what can and can't happen it is my
understanding
in this governing legislation it is very
specific
that no new right of ways would be
issued
furthermore no new roads may be
constructed
no easements for utilities granted and
no approval
to enhance or pave existing roads
shall happen within the nca unless in
some way
said improvements enhance
the nca public works in their review of
this planned unit development
specifically
requested this matter of paved legal
access
be demonstrated under analysis current
planning expressed
strong concerns for the procurement of
utilities
water sewer gas electric and garbage to
the future residences
this issue of access and the need for
utilities
and the major hurdles these propose is
not new
and it seems troublesome that the
applicant today
resolved these issues or informed us of
the path
in which they seek these resolutions
approving this application today is a
waste of taxpayer dollars and county
employee time
there are multiple enormous obstacles
that need to be addressed
before a planned unit development can
even be considered
i would ask that this body deny the
application
until the applicant can generate this
information
as requested by your staff thank you
thank you next speaker please
good morning my name is michelle saint
angelo that's st
period a-n-g-e-l-o i reside at three
allegro street in blue diamond village
which is just outside of the red rock
canyon national recreation area and
only a few miles from the proposed
development
i serve as volunteer chairwoman of the
cottonwood springs water stewards
which is a committee of save red rock
focused on the conservation of water
for those who are unaware the blue
diamond village water system is
comprised of two wells
tapping a rare natural aquifer which is
recharged by precipitation and snow melt
runoff in the spring mountains
severe drought conditions find the
system significantly taxed
even requiring a lowering of the well
pump back in 2008.
today our well levels are the lowest in
the last four years
in fact we've lost five feet of water
level in just this year
with no rejuvenation in sight
the issue is so dire that in december
the las vegas valley water district
issued a moratorium
on new water commitments for this source
and that moratorium is still in place
today
frankly the addition of 280 homes to the
area
no matter the zoning seems impossible
given the moratorium
not to mention the impending water
shortage in nevada
just recently the u.s bureau of
reclamation stated that by next year
a federally declared water shortage is
expected for the colorado river
this means that nevada will be forced to
reduce its water use
something that warrants a halt in new
residential development
where would we get the water to serve
280 additional families
not to mention a visioned golf course
from a drought-ravaged well
or if the plan is to use city water how
would we conceivably and responsibly
pipe into the most ecologically
significant land
in our county from an over-committed
state source
as you consider this development
proposal my request is that proper
surveying and
research be done to protect the existing
water commitments
on both the blue diamond and the las
vegas valley water systems
moving ahead with approvals of new
housing in a time when basic utilities
are not guaranteed
could lead to an environmental and
public health disaster
please don't risk the lives of all who
currently depend on this stressed water
supply
thank you thank you
okay thanks speaker
good morning commissioners and
thank you for your service my name is
barbara luke l-u-k-e
i live at 16 bojangles way in blue
diamond i'm currently
the chair of the red rock citizens
advisory council but i'm speaking today
as a private individual
well based on what you've already heard
from the public comments i hope that
you're not going to vote
on this today but i do want to make my
own two comments which are
first of all if you do decide to
plan seriously and consider the grading
plan for quote-unquote reclamation of
the
mine please think about other potential
uses for this site we know that this
site has gone through many different
plans and iterations and there may be
more coming in the future
we know that the owner has tried to
negotiate with the federal government
for a land swap and
i believe that the best eventual use for
this land would be a solar power site so
when you're thinking about the grading
requests that they've made
please please consider other possible
uses for the site
my bigger concern is is one that you've
already heard which is site access
the issue of site access needs to be
resolved with the blm before
the commission gets into the sorts of
details that they're being asked to
consider today
i don't agree with the current plan to
have the access
on the mine hall road that's currently
used as the mine hall road
this would bring a new public road into
our national conservation area and of
course it would also add traffic to our
existing uh major road going through
there which is also a state scenic byway
um i do agree with a previous uh
recommended or require i guess it was a
directive
from this commission that access be to
the east i understand that
that's not a requirement if they're if
they've changed
to change the plan to what they have now
but i still
believe that that should be should be
held to by
your commission and ideally the very
best access
solution would be a direct connection to
the 215.
thank you very much okay thank you
next speaker please
good morning my name is kevin mcginn
spelled m-c-g-i-n-n
i live at 22 cerrito in blue diamond
village
i'm here on behalf of the blue diamond
volunteer fire department i am the chief
of station 80 world division
there's 11 volunteer fire stations in
clark county
i happen to be a blue diamond i'm the
chief there and
my question is what happens with me
getting my fire truck up that road
i don't have a prepared statement but i
have tried to drive a fire truck up that
road
it's not happening it's not happening it
takes me about eight minutes to get from
my station
to the top of the mine in my squad on a
rescue call
so someone needs to tell me these 280
homes is there a fire
station planned there because the
closest paid station
is a long ways away and i'm a volunteer
station i just got a call now
that's not going to be ran because it's
a volunteer station so
these 280 homes these people know
they're buying a house that
the closest significant chance of
putting out fire
or helping their loved ones in a medical
call is a long ways away at best
so i don't know what their plan is but i
know it didn't involve
looking at how to get a fire truck up
there or a paramedic up there to do
medical calls thank you chief
appreciate that okay next speaker please
john hyatt 8180 places street las vegas
there's lots of legal issues here there
are infrastructure issues
and this parcel as you know has
parcels have a very long history here of
difficulties
and i think it's entirely inappropriate
to approve
this development in this location at
this time
so at a minimum it needs to be held what
i would prefer to see
is it be denied thank you thank you
next speaker please
madam chair and the members of the clark
county commission for the record my name
is valerie kushel k-u-s-c-h-e-l
and i live at 9874 november rain street
communications director for save redrock
a non-profit organization celebrating
its 20th year
of preserving protecting and enhancing
the natural cultural
recreational and scenic resources in and
around red rock canyon national
conservation area
as the communications director i
actively engage with our community
members on a daily basis
we are proud to have over 44 000
supporters including paid supporters and
social media followers
since learning about this agenda item
our members have raised their concerns
sending over 600 emails urging the
commission to keep redrock rule
and preserve the unique experience that
the canyon offers for southern nevadans
as a born and raised las vegas local i
can attest that red rock canyon is a
treasure
held dear to southern nevadans and
visitors from all over the world
as a child i was brought there by my
parents to observe endangered species
like the desert tortoise
as a teenager i would hike there after
school enjoying unparalleled views
and now as a student of the unlv boyd
school of law
i travel to the serene canyon to escape
the realities that await me in the
valley
and my story is not unique save red rock
has persevered for two decades because
of our members
that they share my admiration for the
canyon and that is why on behalf of our
supporters i am urging every
commissioner to deny get some resources
use permit today
safe redrock is not opposed to private
citizens developing their
private property within allowable
planning codes however gypsum resources
has not proven legal access to the
project site
similarly the proposal does not account
for the red rock design overlay district
with the canyon being such a precious
visual and recreational resource for
southern nevadans
the commission should deny or hold the
permit until all information is
available
and the request is in compliance with
the law i thank you for your time and
feel confident you will make the right
decision for your constituents
thank you anyone else wishing to speak
on item 17
or 18. see a nun
oh are you coming down sir did you want
to speak
nope seeing no one else that wants to
speak under public comment i'm going to
go ahead and close the public comment
ask the applicant to come back to maybe
address some of those concerns
madam chair members of the commission
i'd be willing to answer any questions
directly related to the
tentative track map application and the
planned unit development application
before you today
you want to address any of the concerns
from the audience
or you want specific uh well i heard
many concerns i'm not exactly sure madam
chair which which concerns you would
like me to uh
to answer okay how about um rob
i'm gonna ask if you'll help me address
some of the concerns right one of the
concerns was whether this is properly
before the board and it is properly
before the board
it's ripe for decision there's no gag
order or injunction from a court
they fought an application and it's
probably before you to consider
as far as the road is concerned the
settlement agreement only applies
to major projects for increased density
and of course it's not a major project
and it's not seeking increased density
but the the density satisfies the
density standard for the ru zoning
district
the there's a can you know they have to
provide paid legal access before the
final map records because if the map
records you know there's a lot available
for sale it has to have a road to it
so so that applies before the final map
records but they don't have to provide
paved legal access at this point of the
application process
any other questions so me i'm concerned
about the fire i know how hard it is
with volunteer fire departments the
um it does say that they'll have to
comply with emergency access
um with the fire code so that assumes
that
our code says it has to be pa to have
proper access to get there
right these are they'll have to do a
traffic study in compliance and provide
paved legal access so it won't be the
existing mine hall road that
will be there servicing this property it
would be a different road that complies
with the traffic study
and it would be a paid legal access to
the property
and so let me um and i don't know who
the and maybe the right person isn't
here for me to ask
on the um the volunteer fire department
is that one that falls under clark
county's rule
they're not separate like moapa right
no the um the condition is put in by
um fire prevention building and fire
prevention however
there are standards and i i can let
antonio jump in but there are standards
that
the county has for the roadways for
paving for width
for grade all of that sort of thing and
they would
again they would have to as noted they
would have to demonstrate paid legal
access and paid legal access would have
to comply with our standards
they'd also have to comply with um
they'd have to get the paid
legal access from blm and they would
have to get n-dot approval to be able to
access 159.
okay antonio anything
uh i think nancy covered it um they
again they will have to get a grant
and uh they will have to get concurrence
from ndot since 159
is uh n dot um an n dot highway
our minimum access requirements are 32
feet
it has to be paved um because they are
in the non-attainment pm10
area so they will have to comply and
fire should not have an issue getting
to that parcel okay i just have one more
question
in some trying to wear my water
authority hat and my health district
hats
so we are not at the health district um
and at least at the water authority not
approving any septic
um systems neighborhoods whatsoever
because we're trying to stay on top of
that so they would have to comply
with all of the full you needed correct
well if that's a health district
regulation then they'll have to comply
with the health district regulations
that apply at the time that the final
map records
okay yeah we're just at the health
district we've not been approving
any more septics just because of the
nitrates and the nitrate packages
so okay uh commissioners anybody else
have questions
commissioner gibson thank you
i guess the public works uh what is the
nearest
source of water that would serve this
number of homes
oh i might need help with rob i want to
say it's close to hualapai
blue diamond and hualapai oh yes that's
my understanding i think it's blue
diamond wildfire
miles miles away right
and is there so are there public
roads and streets all the way from
that source of water that would enable
service
right to the the neighborhood
or are there the easements we're talking
about are they
across blm property and they've not have
they been applied for
and has the blm expressed any intent
with respect
to those easements well from hualapai
there's the state highways first of all
to get to that property and then
after this uh if it's approved and after
this
application then it would be incumbent
upon
the applicant to to contact blm and
obtain whatever
easements or right-of-way is required by
the blm to be able to
provide those utilities to the property
now whether they have uh began that
process or not i don't know they're
probably waiting
to see whether or not this tenant map is
this application
is approved well that is a question i'd
like the applicant to respond to
is that an application that's been filed
with a blm have you
done anything in respect of the
provision of utility services to the
to the the applicant currently has on
file with the blm
right away application for a roadway
proposed coming from the easterly
direction connecting state route 160 for
this specific
application as rob pointed out we would
file
a new application for uh right away
a grant providing access for vehicular
traffic
as well as infrastructure across
blm properties connecting to this
applicant's property
and all of that would be directed to 159
state road
159 as opposed to 160 is that the plan
that is the plan for this application
that is correct
anybody else have any comments or
questions
okay um
so i guess i'd entertain a motion um to
follow staff's recommendations
if there's no more questions
commissioner jones madam chair
uh i need to make a disclosure in
january 2019 after taking office i
requested an advisory opinion from the
nevada ethics commission regarding
whether i was precluded from voting on
zoning matters involving the applicant
gypsum resources
llc given my prior pro bono legal
representation of save redrock and
litigation brought by clark county
concerning a prior major projects
application based upon the information
that i provided to the ethics commission
regarding my prior representation of say
redrock the ethics commission opined
that i should comply
with the disclosure requirements of
nrs281a
0.421d for a period of one year but that
abstention
was not required to the contrary the
ethics commission emphasized that under
nrs 281a
0.424 there is an express legal
presumption against abstention and that
abstention would divest my constituents
in district f
of my vote on matters of importance to
them although more than two and a half
years has passed since the ethics
command
opinion and all the present gypsum
zoning applications were not brought
onto the major projects process that was
the subject of my prior representation
of say redrock
i am nevertheless hereby disclosing that
i previously represented save redrock
in matters relating to gypsum's major
projects application
including in litigation brought by clark
county in which gypsum was named a party
and which was dismissed by all parties
in november 2018 in 2019 gypsum filed a
lawsuit against clark county in which
gypsum makes allegations of impropriety
against me
including that i have shown personal
animus towards mr jim rhodes
as evidenced by amongst other things a
tongue-in-cheek social media post from
october 31st 2018
and that it failed to disclose all
relevant information to the ethics
commission
given that the ethics commission opinion
principally related to gypsum's major
projects applications
including prior requested waivers and
the intervening lawsuit i would like to
hear the district attorney's position
as to whether i'm required to abstain
from voting on agenda items
17 and 18. okay uh
rob it's the district attorney's opinion
that you may vote on this and that you
do not need to abstain on this
these applications thank you mr warhola
okay any other comments or questions can
i just
uh clarify because i don't remember if i
asked this is
this is no increased density this is
um what it's um zoned for currently
right
that's correct and what is that one
are you zoning which is a one unit for
every two acres
okay just wanted to make sure i forgot
if i asked it
okay uh can we share sega commissioner
bloom
yes um i'm gonna vote in favor of this
just because it's my understanding that
they comply with the zoning but it
sounds to me like there's so many issues
going forward that i'm not really
addressed at this point that
i don't see how they could ever do it
water and everything else but
very basic concept of the land use
matches what they've asked for
then i think at this point we have to
vote in favor
okay commissioner miller i i don't know
if
commissioner jones intends to vote on
this and follow the district attorney's
recommendation it sounds like maybe he
will but
it's obviously his district we're going
to do some redistricting my district's
adjacent to that
uh i'm more than happy to make the
motion for approval
in the absence of mr jones not
make an emotion okay
go ahead red rock's important to
everybody so
go ahead commissioner miller sure i'll
move for approval
as outlined in staff report okay
commissioner miller has
made a motion for approval any further
discussion
i have one other question yep um of our
lawyer we recognize that there is
pending litigation there's been a
concern
expressed by some that there are there
could be or there are issues proceeding
with this
uh application and i take and taking
action on it
please uh respond to that week
right there's no gag order from the
court there's no injunction
uh the matter being litigated is
completely different it has to do with a
uh major project application and the
timing of
a right-of-way that fell under the
settlement agreement
to the east which is to 160. none of
those issues are currently
before you the issue here is completely
different this has to do with their
existing ru zoning
they're proposing access from a
different location that comply with the
zoning
and all the requirements it's just not
an issue that's before the court like i
said it's an application that's before
you
um and like i said there's no gag order
no injunction
nothing no order from the court that
prohibits us from considering this
matter so
it's properly before you
thank you
i'll bring up i guess that's one issue
that was raised the red rock overlays
district it's it's our position that the
red rock overlay district the purpose of
that is to preserve the natural setting
and certainly that's not the case here
because this is clearly the almost or
all of the property is a mining
property has been mined or will be mined
and so really there's no natural setting
to preserve so it's our position
my office's position the district
attorney's office position
that the red rock overlay district does
not apply to this these applications
and that's our opinion that that issue
is really not before you that's really
our opinion on it we've researched the
issue and we believe it's not
um doesn't really apply to this property
because it's been
mine the property has been mined there's
no natural setting to preserve
but that's our that's our position on
the matter
so i guess will they have to come back
before us that any
if they make any substantial changes
they would have to come back and start
over correct
right if the china map the proposed
application has significant changes then
i'll have to come back and
submit another application so i thought
okay there's a motion on the floor by
commissioner miller
any further discussion cnn please cast
your vote
and that motion passes next item please